[Music]
merry christmas everyone love you all
don't ever change nate oy before you go
i have one more christmas surprise for
you it's right
yeah yeah one of my presents to keely is
that i'd stop by and say merry christmas
to you lot so merry christmas well
jingle my bells it's roy kim
what's the matter
i got some on my face no ted that's the
problem there's nothing on your face
your mustache is gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
quick anyone got a mirror here you go
coach i've always got a mirror oh no i'm
supposed to facetime with henry in an
hour he won't recognize me without my
mustache it's gonna ruin christmas don't
worry ted we're on it everyone split up
and find that snot mop
oh i hope they find it i really want
this christmas to be perfect
sorry ted we looked everywhere yes i
searched every inch of the royal opera
house it weren't in ted's car but i
don't have a car jamie
then it wasn't in the person's car whose
window i just smashed with a rock
people we don't need to find ted's
mustache we need to catch it
i built the trap and baited it with a
mustache's favorite things crumbs a
small comb and a tiny bit of pomade nate
that's a kill trap uh you're damned
right it is that thing escaped from
ted's face who knows what it wants next
wait before we kill anything let me try
something
a little more up there and a little just
there
and presto oh i love it i don't know
guys it's not really me you know looks
more like clark gable or john waters
love me
why do you have a disguise kit why don't
you
that's amazing
i think you look fantastic agree to
agree but the whole point is for henry
to recognize me right forgot the
objective
yeah user oy you need a tash yeah
whoa i look like detroit tigers superfan
magnum p.i
but even though this feels like i'm
kissing your forehead
it ain't me roy oh babe i'm gonna miss
your eyebrows hang on
oh you're so hairy disgusting hey it's
no use for the first time in history tom
selleck has ruined christmas
i'll see you all tomorrow
where will he go what will he do frankly
my dear i don't give a damn wow wow is
that clark he's just right oh thank you
obviously i do care it's just the
mustache talking
[Music]
hey guys sorry i was being such a
straight white cisgender male version of
the grinch earlier which i guess is just
ebenezer scrooge don't worry about that
but i realize not having my mustache it
ain't the end of the world cause it's
not about making christmas perfect for
the people you love it's the people you
love that make christmas
perfect is amazing i can't believe my
eyes oh what's wrong now your mustache
is back hot dog eggnog
oh that's henry i'll see you all later
goodbye
christmas merry christmas dad you look
great thanks buddy i actually just
shaved you know what one second big guy
hey everyone have a perfect christmas i
mean an imperfect christmas cause it's
the imperfections that make it well i
mean you get it you saw what we're going
for right
oh is it snowing in my apartment
oh that's weird
[Music]
you